so I'm talking about the javascript is a
compilation target so I want to talk
about Todd dr. JavaScript our compiler
but first who am I so am i stuffed
engineer at Google in in ojos in Denmark
and my previous projects included
schemed its keen to JavaScript compiler
then in my spare time I wrote the
child's get the scheme compiler and I
worked and we ate virtual machines and
and now now dark so my background is
basically scheme and charge give dynamic
languages so what is start it's an
unsurprising of object-oriented
programming language which from many
means it's a boring language a little
bit like Java but that was kind of our
intent it's a gas phase with the sink
inheritance and the syntax is the same
as in Java JavaScript and all these see
like languages and the new thing at
least at that time was the optional
static type system which recently was
seen in touch script too just to give
you a small example here's are the
bottles of beer in Dart nothing nothing
special here so when we only have darts
and we want to deploy it we have two
ways to do it the first of course we
have our dart sources and then ideally
you you put it on the dart virtual
machine and run it fast nice and
everything and if you still have another
browser that doesn't support the dart VM
which currently even chrome doesn't then
you have to compile the JavaScript and
that's and then it should run on all
modern browsers and this talk in
particular is now about this doctor
JavaScript compiler so there were
several goals when we started the the
JavaScript compiler so for one it should
run on all modern browsers and we test
on Chrome Firefox ie and Safari and we
have a testing slot for Oprah we just
haven't fill it in yet it's going to
help me at some point and and our goal
is that that the dart VM is not
necessary so you can program in dart and
it still should still work on process
that don't have to be in and of course
it must be efficient and compact
otherwise nobody wants to use it
so here's another example of dart the
standard point example nothing again
nothing special here we just allocate to
new points and then take the distance
between those two note that in this case
I didn't either i didn't use the type of
notation i just used bar but i could
have used typing annotation to so
pointer or intern or double in this case
so here's the compilation to the chalice
crypt in this in for this example there
are two things that probably stick out
first instead we put statics on I'm
dollar so it's dollar dot instead of
having but instead of polluting the
global namespace and the second one that
you probably actually three things the
second one is that there is no new we
just always go through factory
constructors which has a big advantage
when you have different constructors for
the same class because we in the
background can then use the same
JavaScript gas and have one hidden map
in the virtual machines which basically
means it will run faster the other thing
the third thing is the distance to
dollar one we encode our aerating the in
the names of the methods this way we got
except we get exceptions when the arity
doesn't work and we don't need to check
in arguments the length or anything we
just call and if it doesn't work it
means that either the arity was not was
not right or all the methods didn't
exist so this is basically what I just
said statics on abdallah factory
constructors and functions method calls
are translated to functions with with
the arity in its name so what are the
challenges now one of the big challenge
is closures in fact when we have
JavaScript as I just said or as an
implied doesn't check Verity where's in
doubt it's an error if you if you don't
give the correct number of arguments and
in the previous example which has been
coded the air it in the name of the
method but if you have a closure in the
hand you you don't have a name anymore
so you cannot read encode it there and
the second thing is that in dart we have
a we be allowed named or option
arguments so that's something that would
be annoying to encode inside the closure
too and we are also instant
object instances so cars instances to be
invoked as if they were closures and
their everything breaks down we cannot
use the childish cape Dakota the
challenge crypto just as target for
watch out for dart closures next one the
next challenge is its operators
javascript is very lenient in what it
accepts for operator arguments in fact
it will just try to convert it to
numbers or strings and carry on it will
keep on truckin there's nothing that
will basically throw an exception or
I'll give an error and we don't want
that we want to have we want to have
exceptions when when things don't don't
work where God and the second one is
that in darkly I have user-defined
operators so we allow to override the +
operator the minus operator and so on
and therefore we cannot just compile to
the challenge k plus because for many
objects it wouldn't work and finally in
the little bit in a similar area is the
array axises in JavaScript rare exes are
not checked for out of bounds or what
what the key actually is the links
operator and JavaScript works on any
object it accepts everything starting
with integers doubles objects strings
and in some cases it merges them as you
can see the the a of the string 1 is
similar to calling a of one so all those
things are invalid in dart and we need
to check those so what what are the
solutions that we came up with so
foreclosures there's actually a pretty
easy solution we compile closures two
new classes which and these gases have a
feeds for for free variables and
sometimes boxes four for four barrels
that are mutated and then we just put
normal methods on them as if there were
normal classes and we treat them
internally as as classes basically and
that's that's working pretty well for
two reasons one is that allocating a
small objects in JavaScript is very fast
and allocating a closure and javascript
is smallest size emphasized at the same
size as six fees and the second is that
every JavaScript engine has heavily
optimized the method excesses and in
there in the lurch it's just because
every benchmark uses that heavily so in
the end you are usually as fast or
faster than if you had action closures
so as an example here we have a closure
a dart closure which starts with the
they each going to the list index off so
this is a shorthand form for for
creating a closure and art so the list
of map takes the closures that itself
takes in each end and searches for the
for this element in the list and this is
translated you have the tart under on
the bottom this is translated into a
main dollar closure class so the second
second part which has one field the list
so that was a free variable and it has
one method the cold other one which
represents the invocation target if you
invoke the closure and in there it's
just a normal function which takes an
argument and does whatever we wanted to
do before note the compact gas
representation so we avoid a lot of
particle by the plate code by by
generating an occult dynamically this
way we shrink a little bit the size of
the JavaScript the resulting JavaScript
so the second problem was was the
operators and there the knave solution
would be to just add functions on the
prototypes of numbers erased rings pool
enzymes on and and invoke these methods
instead of using the child script
operates directly so you could imagine
having an ad operator on the prototype
of number that takes another argument
and only if that argument is actually
number we return the the sum of this
plus plus X and similarly for array the
index operator we would check that the
that the index is an integer and only if
it's in its then also in the bounds we
return the the axis of this so I have
the effort to example standard so X plus
y would then be compared to X dot add of
Y and similarly lists the operator
please
the index operator list I would be a
method call to the list so the drawbacks
of the solution is that it pollutes the
global objects which is something we
really want to avoid and it also can be
very slow especially if you if you if
you don't have a strict mode the reason
is that when you do a method call on our
numbers or number boolean's and so on it
will box the object before it can do the
the action method call so what we did
instead is having having static
interceptors so we just have static
methods that represent the operators and
the they are polymorphic in the sense
that for every operator that is for
native sorry for native up for native
JavaScript objects we intercept them in
these static functions so we check if
it's a number and if the other one is a
number we do the operation if it's if
it's something else that supports them
plus operator we we would do it in there
too so we just intercept operators in a
static function and then only redirect
to the data object if if it's not a
child shipped primitive similarly for
for the index operator will check if
it's a JavaScript array if it is we do
the child script stuff and if it's not
we will redirect to the dart method so
to give you an example of how that looks
in the code this is just a small main
that loop that gets the summer of a list
and this is still pretty readable so
every operator is replaced with a call
to aesthetic sodala dot in one case it's
the less than bully fires in the other
one it's the ad and then we have an
index so pretty standard stuff nothing
nothing special and that works the only
problem is that is very slow so we had a
if you do it this way you have a snow
level slowdown of about a factor of six
compared to handwritten JavaScript code
on on v8 and in some cases it even goes
down to 23 times slower than handwritten
code and there and there some really
obvious improvements you don't need to
use an operator if you actually know the
type of the arguments
this case you can simulate the in lining
of this static function call and avoid
the da'kel to the global interceptor so
by tracking the types and in particular
the local types we can and doing a
little bit of type inference we can
improve massively on that on that code
going back to the example that we had
before instead of having all these
method calls to the sorry instead of
having all the static calls to the
interceptors we now have only we have
none left in this example every
everywhere place is known the type is
known so we know that the list is an
array we know that the integers that the
sum is a number we know that I is an
integer the only thing we actually still
have to do is to do the checks so we
need to check that we don't have an
out-of-range exception and we don't have
an illegal argument exception in case we
have a plus of a number plus something
that is not a number both can be in line
easily and are pretty fast so doing just
that gives us a performance compared to
handwritten JavaScript code of a
50-percent even a little bit more and
it's a good start to continue from there
on there are two things that are to be
noted here the better your global type
reference is the less study calls you
have so the better you get and our
global type of options are girding is
currently not that well not that good
something we were going to work on soon
and even if you have a global type
inference algorithm that is pretty good
you will still have a lot of calls to
interceptors in case when you lose track
of the types and these are doubly
expensive because for one you have to
study interceptor calls and the second
one is you don't know if they have side
effects and therefore they destroy your
local optimizations so the big hammer we
have for that is the speculative
optimizations and that's the yeah so the
idea is to guess what the type of the of
the verbal would be or instruction what
the type would be based on on how it's
used and then we try to optimize for
this speculated type
and the promise of course we cannot
always be right and therefore we have
bailouts when we are wrong so the give
you an idea here this is the same
example as before the the sum of the
loop except that in this case we have no
idea what X is in the previous example
we knew it was a list it was in the code
in this example it could be anything but
looking at the code it put a really
great if it was a child script array so
what we do now is we just say okay let's
check if it's a JavaScript array and if
it is and so if it is not one we bail
out but if it is one we can optimize the
same as before we have this perfect code
that is a running nicely and fast but
not perfect but nearly perfect and then
if we are wrong well we have a bailout
function that does the expensive static
interceptor calls and does the does the
necessary stuff to get it right in case
there's an operator overloading and it's
not a list and and all these things the
thing is that if you do that all the
time you blow up your code so we have
some heuristics 22 when we want to check
when we want to speculate and it's
difficult to see when and how we need to
do that and currently we just physically
say if you're using something from
inside a loop and ideally transitively
from inside the loop so if you call a
function that is in from inside a loop
you will also optimize that function
speculatively then we do speculative
optimizations if I were is just a
function somewhere we ok we don't care
we keep their two interceptors ideally
and that's that's future work we want to
do profile guided optimizations so we
want to say speculate everything and
then tell us later on what worked and
what didn't work and things that either
always made out or never wear called we
can't just leave the the course the
static interceptors and would have
nicely reduced code size so with that we
get another huge bump in performance and
it really really paid so with that we
have about 75% of handwritten code and
together a little bit on the speed space
V trade off with the speculative
optimizations we have about fifty
percent code increase when we when we
enable the speculative optimizations
using heuristics and even if we didn't
use heuristics it would only blow up I
fact them by seventy two percent so for
profiling for instance it would still be
feasible to have all speculative sin and
then see which ones are actually
effective yes there's another thing we
do to reduce the code size that's tree
shaking the idea here is that we only
compile functions that are potentially
reach able so we start with the main
which is the only entry point in Dart
you cannot execute code outside of main
and then we look at yes colors of Ada
and then we look at the at what is
invoked and what classes are
instantiated and songs in this case you
have two classes that extent that are
instantiated that is pointed line and
you have one method call that that's the
distance to and then from there on since
it's a method called you collect all the
classes they're there and see I'm sorry
you collect all the the methods that are
possible in this case let's assume point
and line have a distance to method on
them and you continue recursively
enumerate the functions that are
potentially reachable in this case you
would could be for instance square root
and a cross product and point and so as
you can see in this example you might
end up compiling too much nothing in the
code that is shown at least tells you
that you call line the distance off the
only one that is there is a point of
distance to so it distance to but the
it's still a good it still reduces the
code size ballot and the more typing
information you have the better it gets
so another in another diagram saying the
same thing what we do is we start by
parsing the whole code but diet parsing
which means that we don't actually
create the ast for everything we just
get the structures what other classes
without a method and so on then we
resolve using the tree shaking algorithm
and there we actually put the HTS and
then at the end we do another we do
another tree shaking while tree shaking
like compilation process where we where
we are compiled only the methods that
are actually called knowing that
the compilation might do that code
elimination and so on and that's why the
the compiled code could be less than the
results code since we are coming out
compilation I'm not going to the symbol
single static single assignment form so
we this is the the the how we compiled
we have we start with the dark syntax
tree then go for a pillow that builds
our SS a graph go to some optimizations
on that a lot of optimizations on that
and then go to the go to narita which
which code generator which will produce
the challenge syntax tree which
will then emit to get the final code so
the single static assignment form is
commonly used in tons of compilers and
we use it for for analysis and
optimizations too in particular we have
the local type inference which uses the
ESS a phone function in i link is well
it's kind of on the on the builder level
but partially on the SS a cuba value
numbering and i'm going to give a slide
on that one also the loop invariant code
motion i have a slight just afterwards
and finding the range propagation where
we just keep track of the ragged ranges
a variable can have note that s sa is
actually pretty annoying in in in some
respect when you compile to challenge
good because going out of charge of the
SS a form back to charge Gabe it's not
always trivial because there's no goat
in JavaScript there it can be tricky to
to to actually compiled back to tonights
challenge group and we spend a lot of
time on that so the club value numbering
I mentioned it basically just tries to
avoid recomputing stuff if you already
have computed it so in this case
compiler that generated assuming that we
know that compiler generated is not a
getter we can avoid accessing it twice
just doing it once before the diff and
therefore avoiding a little bit of code
end of execution in the same way in
looping around commotion if we can show
that we can hoist a computation out of a
loop well let's
do that it's as simple as that funny
enough most of those are not that
important for us because the the chit's
then do that already so only a few cases
where we have a little bit better
information than the chips can we can we
do do we do more than they do but it's
still it still gave us some percentages
here's now the the same actor that's
some example from before up with the
optimizations apply there are only two
changes from before for one we have now
the listed length which is a hoisted out
of the loop so that's the VAR t one then
and the second one is that the range
propagation made sure that we don't need
to check for for the out of bounds
exception in it other than that no
change so what's the status of the dart
to JavaScript compiler with respect to
code size we are we have improved a lot
since our first release so everybody
still remembers the mega byte header
world that's not the animal and usually
now if you have actually if you have an
app that loses a lot of charge gift code
is because you just libraries so it's
not that we cannot make our code bed and
we can definitely make it better but in
many cases now it's not not stupid
errors anymore stupid code generation as
there was before and we are working on a
mini fire already so we have and dart
dart mini fire and we have minification
for javascript where we remove the white
space at least and we are working on on
with minifying the local variables names
and everything to with respect to
performance this is a screenshot of our
internal tracker the important one is
probably did the last number on the
bottom and the right which is the dart
to JavaScript performance with compared
to v8 to handwritten v8 code so the gr
NT geometric means says that we are now
at seventy-eight percent of the
handwritten code at least for the
benchmarks we have here and we would
think we can still improve on that so
it's not yet it's not yet done
and then some benchmarks veeram in the
fastest some so as conclusion
speculative optimizations I think that's
the big takeaway from this talk it's a
it's crucial to get a real good
performance if you have dynamic code and
we are now more than seventy-five
percent speed of handwritten JavaScript
code so it's a good time to give that
another try if you have done it before
in a try if you hadn't and with that I
thank you and I will take questions
do have any questions out there all
right the loop invariant code motion
where and how do you have more
information than digit on do you have a
concrete case where you know more than
digit and can do better at the top of my
head I don't but I'm pretty sure there
are some cases where we compiled
something into a method call just
because it simpler because we don't want
to learn it and we still know that this
method call is it doesn't have any any
side effect and if the vm doesn't ignite
it it will not see the same thing and
also doing this might help us optimize
ourselves call ourselves so if we can
basically bail out earlier thats that's
the biggest thing if we can move it out
of the loop and then have a bailout that
is not inside the loop but outside the
loop be much faster so you briefly
mentioned hello hi you briefly mentioned
getters and of course in es6 we're gonna
be getting proxies which all make this I
imagine a lot harder do you have a
strategy for dealing with that or rpms
and compile to jeaious languages and
optimizations in general just kind of
screwed ones proxies roll around and
once getters start being more prevalent
well first it shouldn't matter because
we compiled to challenge crypt so as
long as the current set doesn't change
the current language doesn't change we
should be fine on the other hand it
could help us so for instance getters
and setters when we started out to
JavaScript it was just a no-go we
couldn't compile dart getters and
setters to JavaScript getters and
setters because they were horrendously
slow where's now I think there are some
benchmarks appearing that actually use
it so which its start to optimize them
so everything that comes into javascript
is just helping us
actually I have two questions one what
if you have a jquery on your page like
dollar sign is kind of very popular and
neither do you have a telco recursion
sorry do you have a tail call
optimization in art or not and if you do
what do you compile to ok so a second
question is easy to know we don't have
it and the first question is at the
moment there is a conflict but we can
easily change dollar to something else
there is no that that's that's really
easy so you mentioned minification at
the end that you might add that in are
there specific thing piece of
information you have in dart that you
think could help with minification
beyond just what you can get from a
post-hoc minna fire so fast minification
is much easier than for child can I hope
I responding to a question because we
don't have dynamic codes générateur
amoco generation or even accessing
through strings as long as you of course
don't use on mirrors which is reflection
so as long as you don't use reflection
we can just minify every method to the
corresponding minified the name and we
know that it will not be a problem
because nobody can use a string to
access it or nobody can generate new
code to do that so from that it seems
pretty just having a map from 24 methods
statics and everything should do the job
tree shaking if I said it correctly
wouldn't work with library code but
would it work if you included all your
or if you recompile your library card
together with the application that's the
spot video when you compile from dart to
JavaScript we take the whole code we put
it into one violent and which we shake
everything away and we have the dart
dart compiler to do basically the same
thing when you when you deploy on tart
any other questions all right cool thank
you for learning very much